musique
[Musique]
sans les je crois bien j'ai décollent ou
atterrissent a déclaré blaise de la
métropole
trou et mon cerveau à l'aide une
chignole titualire de mon doigt la
couleur de manière
mon niveau
le dîner
[Musique]
nancy battu
dans ses mains pour iphone
dit 'ne
[Musique]
sur les seuls métiers
je m'éclate des turbines dans le miroir
aux alouettes avec une cuisine je
cueille les ablettes cette matière grise
et bleue je n'ai plus d'idées noires
jorane ouvrent le feu ce règne entamé
mois
on
nous dînons
[Musique]
petit
bout puis en
mai
[Musique]
key
les yeux le seul utile
oui
son blazer de la vie du crooner je vais
t'offrir mais le nuit mais il faut pas
tu t'en fuir vous mais moi tu jour met
au jour les jours la folie des vendeurs
ou pas dans la peur du jugement
dit
le dit
et
[Musique]
qui nous
10 noeuds le dire
j'aime la vie
mais qu'il le savait
[Musique]
voilà